enfin c'est un veau axel kahn c'est
parce que vous êtes généticien que vous
avez plus de cheveux que votre frère non
non c'est parce que j'ai 6 ans de moins
je crains qu'à son âge ce soit à peu
près pareil alors dans votre livre vous
aussi vous parler du monde tels qui va
mais à travers un prisme plus intime une
lettre que vous allez c'est votre père à
sa mort et qui se termine par ces mots
soient raisonnables et humain et c'est
le titre du livre publié chez nil
éditions alors reprendre les choses 2 0
comment s'appelle camille fériau votre
père s'appelle jean kahn s'appelait jean
kahn
professeur de philosophie résistant sous
le nom de fériau et vous aviez un
troisième frère olivier décédé en 1999
alors j'ai été élevé vous chez les chez
les jésuites à pontlevoy un oui c'est
vrai ça et vous jean-françois faisait
péter les jésuites
on sait même pas qu'il avait élevé chez
cegid eu des coûts connus et que ne rien
de moi voyez cette entité il a été
blessé léger selon eelv énorme et j'ai
géré c'est un nom à pontlevoy équipe
tout à fait vrai et en fait j'ai compris
l'origine juive de votre père en fait à
l'âge de 15 ans quand quelqu'un dans la
cour de récréation vous a traité de sale
juif chrétien catholique en forme de
coeur c'est même pas que j'aime a
cherché catholique après ce n'est pas le
problème mais le problème juif
effectivement ne m'était jamais apparu
moins étaient scouts de france
catholique
notre mère avait été et puis dans ce
collège de pontlevoy où il y avait des
bons bourgeois il y à un vicomte yann de
cargoët qui est un jeu on s'était girl'
et comme une querelle de gauche quoi il
m'a traitée de sale juif alors j'ai
regardé un peu bizarre en disant
pourquoi une traite de sale juif d'abord
j'ai été très propre sur moi n'y avait
pas de raison et c'est pas ça et puis
bon j'ai peut-être même un peu plus loin
et je me suis dit que j'avais peut-être
quelque chose à voir avec le fait que
l'on m'a vidic en effet kahn était un
ange est exempt mais auparavant dans la
famille ça n'a jamais été un problème
qui s'est posé entre nous c'est vrai
c'est un coin si vous avez fait votre
promesse de scouts à lourdes en dans le
vrai chemin
non vous savez chaque je sais pas
faut dire alors jusqu'à 15 ans n'ont
voulu être prêtre et puis ensuite vous
perdez la fois et vous savez pourquoi
j'ai pas été prêtre non c'est tout
simplement qu'avant d'être évêque
monseigneur kahn juge était la bécane et
ça c'est dur arrive n'est pas gagné pour
la déconne avec m
[Applaudissements]
finalement une carte gens bien sûr et je
voulais qu'on ait une pensée pour mon
ami la bnp qui doit sent moins seul
ensuite vous perdez la fois que c'est le
cas mais puis vous êtes communiste de
1975 1977 1-1 et en 68 il est arrivé une
histoire absolument extraordinaire donc
à l'époque vous êtes en afrique médecin
chef d'un accident de voiture
on vous rapatrie à l'hôpital du val de
grâce vous sortez de l'hôpital avec les
pansements en plein mai 68 et les gens
vous prennent pour un pour un héros pour
un héros de la révolution de 68 et vous
voulez laisser dire d'abord j'étais très
étonnée je trouvais que tous les gens
étaient blancs vraiment d'abord inusité
pour moi ça faisait 20 ans que j'étais
en afrique
et puis il ya des jeux je regarde
j'avais entendu qu'il y avait eu des
événements quand même donc je regarde le
quartier latin après la nuit des
barricades le pays à ce moment là il ya
un groupe effectivement qu'ils me voient
j'avais une cicatrice ici un blad un
bras dans le plâtre des pansements un
peu partout et puis qui se met à me
porter en triomphe
et j'ai compris que ils pensaient que
j'avais reçu cela de haute lutte contre
le crs conneries des conneries et c'est
vrai que sur le moment j'ai été tout à
fait lâche je les ai pas d tromper je me
suis dit que j'étais supporter comme un
héros qu'axel notre merci pour ton
honnêteté
vous savez que le comble c'est que moi
j'ai vraiment été blessés en mai 68
c'est doublement incombe d'abord parce
que j'étais pas favorable et d'autre
part parce que personne n'a perdu la vie
en août
même maintenant alors votre père à tous
les deux lui voit en revanche 168 à un
aboutissement à tous les deux pas sûr
c'est pas le généticien qui contredira
non sûrement pas peut-être vous savez la
filiation elle est affective de ce point
de vue là nous sommes frères essaient de
notre père lors donc votre père voit lui
en revanche dans 68 l'aboutissement de
ses espérances
il loue une chambre au quartier latin et
il y croit vraiment le problème de papa
durant la guerre a fait de la résistance
et il a été communiste 1 il a été jeune
communiste il est fait [ __ ] à la porte
comme beaucoup d'intellectuels à
l'époque est très très attachée à la
résidence irigo liste il est tellement
gaulliste free alice voilà et ils votent
toujours lors du retour du général de
gaulle au pouvoir ils votent toujours
oui pour le j'imagine pour le pl est
parti gaulliste successifs
et oui aux différents référendum du
général de gaulle et puis d'un seul coup
il ya 68
il ya 68 et l'homme de gauche le
révolutionnaire qu'il est l'idéaliste
qu'il acquit qui veut véritablement un
monde qui correspondent plus à ses
aspirations
il a l'impression que ce monde là il est
en train d'émerger
et effectivement je n'ai pas vu mais
j'ai lu ce qu'il a écrit à ce moment là
effectivement il a un espoir fou un
moment donné il se dit ça y est non
seulement ça se passe mais encore je
suis là et je vais j'ai assisté et
qu'est-ce qui se passe d'abord il y a
effectivement cette révolutionnaire qui
s'écroule assez lamentablement et
d'autre part ceux qui l'achève ce sont
les gaullistes donc au référendum qui
suit en 69 pour la première fois de ces
votre nom et votre nom et pour lui c'est
un drame terrible c'est le drame qui est
liée à l'échec de cette ce mouvement
auquel il avait cru dont ils pensaient
qu'ils allaient refaire le monde et
c'est également l'échec de cette
fidélité à un général de gaulle donc ça
montre les la déshérence l'espèce de
désespoir dans quelle ville salingue et
deux ans plus tard en 1970 il ya
d'autres circonstances mais il a
l'impression que le monde qui
l'entourent l'a fait prisonnier et qui
peut plus s'en échapper et que la seule
possibilité effectivement c'est de
voyager prend le train et puis il y
avait une autre raison il ya cela bien
sûr ce qu'il ya une autre raison c'est
que c'etait un
un intellectuel pur un idéaliste pure et
qu' il ne supportait pas l'oppression de
l'argent ouais c'est quelque chose qui
ne supportent or il était toujours
rattrapé par le problème de l'argent
sans arrêt et je crois que ça a beaucoup
contribué aussi à sa mort car tout ça
évidemment l'emmène au suicide et un
jour il se jette du train à
mantes-la-jolie c'est un nom terrible
pour un suicide et il laisse une lettre
pour vous sur un fauteuil d'un d'un
wagon et qui se termine par soient
raisonnables et humain ce qui est le
titre comme je les dis de votre livre
alors motif c'est un petit peu un bilan
d'étape vous vous dites est ce que
jusque là finalement est-ce que j'ai été
raisonnable et humain quel serait le
jugement de mon père par rapport à tout
ce que j'ai fait par rapport à ce que je
pense à ce que j'ai écrit et là vous
passez en revue tous les grands
problèmes du monde d'abord des problèmes
d'éthique le suicide l'euthanasie
l'hominisation et là on en vient à un
truc que jean marie dit dans son
spectacle tous les soirs dire que vous
dites qu effectivement toutes les races
sont les mêmes génétiquement on dérive
tous doit être démocratique africain qui
a quitté l'afrique il ya environ 70
milles ans et qui a peuplé le tout le
monde par le détroit de béring et de au
sujet de l'hominisation vous dit
effectivement que les chimpanzés en a
même séquence génétique que l'homme
comment ces joyaux alors celle qu'elle
est le propre de l'homme donc c'est
toute la question
alors je veux dire propre de l'homme
chez qui un primate notre ancêtre qui
s'est mis à fabriquer des outils sas et
avantages de fabriquer des outils pour
se défendre contre l'environnement qui
est hostile comme chacun sait et c'est
tout petit c'est déjà une culture et on
sait très bien qu'au contact de la
culture on sa culture c'est à dire on
développe sa capacité intellectuelle et
l'homme avait un cerveau qui était déjà
suffisamment gros pour pouvoir être
impressionnable sensible à les bouches
de culture qu'il crée et donc il est
devenu un peu plus intelligent il a créé
une culture plus riches
il est devenu plus intelligent sera à
partir d'un moment donné l'évolution de
l'homme et c'est la première fois que
cela se passait sur la terre a cessé
d'être parallèle à une évolution
biologique à revenir une évolution
culturelle est le propre de l'homme
c'est un primate un animal chez lequel à
un moment donné l'évolution pour
l'essentiel l'évolution de ses us et
coutumes de ses moeurs a cessé d'être un
phénomène
biologique pour devenir un phénomène
culturel l'homme a inventé l'évolution
civilisationnel peut-être que demain les
sages où les cétacés le ferons mais pour
l'instant la seule ville à 30 très
intelligente qui a dit un jour sara
rejoint la discussion tout à l'air
gentil en parlant de personnes très
intelligentes de nous montrer tous les
deux je m'en sers énergique mais il
disait peu m'importe de savoir si
l'homme descend du singe le tout c'est
de ne pas y retourner et apparemment on
est dans une période où il faut se poser
des questions elle avait tout à fait
rire c'est que je veux que de mon
spectacle il ya trois grandes
différences qui séparent dany massé
comme à la conscience de sa conscience
qu'il a un langage articulé complet ce
qui à mon avis est la plus importante et
il sait qu'il va mourir alors que
l'animal ne sais pas ce que dernier
moment il est possible qu'un éléphant
par exemple on voit très bien à la fin
de celle aux bouchons clair un voyage et
c'est souvent compliqué une question est
ce que c'est pas la bipédie qu'était le
détonateur de tours il ya un certain
nombre de découvertes actuelles qui
tendent à montrer qu en effet à certain
nombre de saints jeu qu'on ne connaît
pas encore mais qui ne sont pas vraiment
des hommes est la leur ligne a été perdu
un certain nombre de sages ou était
bipède
bon cela dit la bipédie est un facteur y
aurait pas eu loeb sans la bipédie et la
bipédie a quand même autre outre à
conséquences que ça dégage les mains et
que ça permet des mains de faire un
outil ça une autre conséquence c'est que
dans la mesure où la tête repose sur un
socle stable cirque on ne la portent
plus comme lorsqu'on marche est
incapable du coup le cerveau pour
grossir
slattery en plus on voit les ennemis de
loin comme on voit le sexe du voisin ça
favorise la sexualité les rôtis et le
troisième élément c'est que jusqu'à ce
que loeb ou le singe seul se lève ce
qu'était le sens principal c'était la
jeunesse culture on se on se gardait par
le nez on juger l'autre par le nez tout
se faisait par l'odeur or l'homme enfin
ou le singe près homme en se levant tout
à coup c'est l'oeil qui devient
fondamental
d'où le signe est derrière
signal il ya peut-être le langage le
langage des signes peut-être langage en
phase études lorsque des gens sont
intelligents françois et raisonnable a
signé signer pro pas que ce soit pas
totalement vrai notamment pour ce qui
est de son frère mais toi
[Musique]
l'état
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu